what are you guys thoughts on bitcoins
reaction to the liquidity crisis or
liquidity trap that was caused by kovat
so obviously there was this massive
sell-off in most asset classes Bitcoin
at one point kind of that Black Thursday
or whatever you want to call it sold off
50% ended the day down about 30 there's
a lot of people who are saying hey this
looks pretty correlated to me and also
it doesn't look like so much of a safe
haven type asset kind of how do you guys
look at what was transpired over the
last six weeks or so sure so I'd say
we're still very far from returning to
kind of business as usual so there's
questions definitely that remain as to
you know when we'll get back on our on
the horse and and that like I really
know the timetable there is but I think
it's been very interesting to your point
to see kind of bitcoins response to kind
of the recent uncertainty we there's
some great work that's been put out by
you know the coin metrics of the world
as a recent piece from the CEO of X PTO
who shared his views I think there are a
few things that we need to consider here
first is that what in a crisis whether
it's coronavirus or financial crisis or
geopolitical crisis there's always a
crisis of liquidity and there's a
vicious cycle that occurs where you have
basically over levered investors who
need to sell across asset classes across
every asset class and that creates kind
of a rush to liquidity where the comfort
of cash basically drives relations to
one and I say this because I think it's
been interesting to see how we've seen
this evolution of narratives around
Bitcoin during coronavirus where to your
point there have been these two
competing narratives that have now been
heavily questioned during this first
quarter
the first is again Bitcoin as this
uncorrelated financial asset second is
Bitcoin as this kind of safe haven asset
when we look back at the month of March
I don't think people were expecting to
see it as severe the drop as what we saw
it was for any Bitcoin suffered its
second largest daily drawdown in press
history and I think it was less than 15
minutes you saw it go from 7,200 down to
5400 it broke it's 200 moving average
for the first time in seven years and
then can continue to sink below 4k and
post sell up we realize that one of the
largest contributors was let me be kind
of these Bitcoin liquidations to satisfy
margin calls on kind of Nexus of the
world where you solve it Nick's on Black
Thursday had almost a billion dollars in
liquidations which is the most over a
24-hour period in years and you combine
that with kind of the exchange outages
that it saw and all the uncertainty
around growing coronavirus and so you
kind of get this kind of natural self
what was interesting to see and you
actually mentioned this with kathy was
that it appears that the speculators
were flushed out and that longer term
investors continue to hold and and so if
we're true believers in Bitcoin the
fundamentals haven't changed and when
you dig into the numbers in core metrics
show it shows this some of the most most
of the sellers were actually short-term
holders and so if you take a look at
bitcoins revive supply which is how many
old coins came back into circulation
after being untouched for a specific
period of time the vast majority of of
the activity involved Bitcoin that had
been that that had been held for less
than a year and so this kind of suggests
that long-term holders really appeared
on faced at the same time you had this
sell-off that was severe and it wasn't
tandem with nepeta market sell-off and
so there are legitimate questions that
are raised around bitcoins if bitcoin is
worthy of allocation if its claim to
fame narrative is around its non
correlation and it's safe haven
attributes if
the numbers the historically Bitcoin has
been relatively uncorrelated with let's
say the SP since since 2012 the the
correlation has been roughly between
negative point 15 to point 15 which is
pretty low correlation over this last
month that kind of increased to new
all-time highs and so the question then
becomes does the recent correlation then
justify people saying that Bitcoin in
the S&P are now suddenly correlated and
the answer I would say as many would say
is probably not and so although you saw
these short-term correlations shoot up
you have to recognize that they were
under very unique market circumstances
you had the news of the spreading of the
Corona buyers that continue to grow
you saw investors across every asset
class rushing into cash and backed into
my earlier point in any risk off
environment it seems like there's really
no safety especially not something
that's like you know has this thinning
of order book says something like
Bitcoin that where a lot of the activity
and trading activity is driven by
speculation but I mean we even saw this
with gold right the correlation between
the S&P and gold was also tied since
2013 and so I think that we're going to
see some sort of kind of reversion to
the mean between Bitcoin and SP but that
in the short term there may very well be
kind of strong high correlation between
the two on the safe-haven asset side I
would say you know gold has
traditionally been used as that primary
example of the safe haven asset and many
like to coin Bitcoin as a digital gold
and so you know usually in uncertain
times you see the price of gold
increased relative to other asset
classes and in Bitcoin Gold's
correlation historically has been
relatively low like they haven't had
there hasn't been very strong
correlation in fact at the extremes
they've been negative and
when we saw Bitcoin and bullets
correlation also spiked up in March
similar to Bitcoin in an SMP and Bouldin
SP you know does that mean that gold
also failed as a safe-haven asset and
and I would say the answer there is also
probably not where you you start trivial
as that although Bitcoin and gold may
not have to say given assets during kind
of a little pandemic they may act as a
safe haven asset you know in times of
monetary inflation or QE and so you know
let's say given the recent trillion
dollar injections that we've seen from
the Fed it's possible that you have big
point like gold that may act as a safe
haven response to some events but not
others and so that's kind of where where
I where I where extent with kind of our
reaction where it's like you know we
could be in the midst of what could be
an interesting inflection point where if
you continue to see kind of central
bank's inject these money into the
economy at these rates then you know
then it could act as that safe haven
during that particular shock but really
the broader point is that fundamentals
haven't changed that they're nice that
bitcoin is still working as designed its
producing roughly you know you know a
block every 10 minutes it has an audible
transparent supply and it enables kind
of permissionless mortgage and transfer
of value so